hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast protein profiling at the tumor
microenvironment role of human primary
fibroblast derived exosomes and oral
cancer progression by dr. Simona
principe i am dr. trash schwartz senior
application scientist at beckman coulter
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we were delighted to bring you
this educational webinar presented by
lab roots and sponsored by Beckman
Coulter agriculture is a leader in
Central Gatien and flow cytometry and
has long been an innovator and particle
characterization lab automation and
genomics Beckman Coulter culture
products are used at the forefront of
important areas of investigation
discovery for more information please
visit beckman coulter com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box at the lower left of the
presentation we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge a
slide window by clicking on the icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
if you have any technical problems
viewing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems for the green Q&A button I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Simona principe simota
completed her PhD in immunopharmacology
in italy and she is currently conducting
postdoctoral research in the lab of dr.
thomas kissinger at the Prince Princess
Margaret Cancer Centre in Toronto Canada
her research interests focuses on
applying proteomic technologies to
investigate cancer biology in particular
she studies the role of secreted
extracellular vesicles as novel
intracellular meet single signaling
mediators within the tumor
microenvironment that support cancer
progression and metastasis since 2012
she has published five papers and
reviews in the field of proteomics and
exosomes before we get started I would
like to ask a few poll questions
our first question is what is your
current isolation method for
extracellular vesicles please select
multiple answers differential
centrifugation density gradient
centrifugation immunoaffinity capture
other or I don't isolate V's will take a
few moments for the answers to populate
it looks like actually the majority of
folks in attendance do not isolate v's
the 26.5 percent use differential
centrifugation 5.9 percent use immune
affinity capture two-point-nine percent
at density gradient centrifugation and
two-point-nine percent at other our
second and final question how do you
analyze the purity of your Eevee's again
please select multiple answers just a
few more moments to allow the answers to
populate all right it looks like
thirty-five percent actually do not
check for purity whereas nineteen
percent used nano particle tracking
analysis nineteen percent use electron
microscopy and thirteen and a half
percent use protein absorbance ratio and
another thirteen and a half percent use
dynamic light scattering thank you
everyone for your answers I will now
turn it over to dr. principe for her
presentation thanks Chad for the very
nice introduction and thank you
everybody for taking the time today to
listen to my webinar so today I'll be
talking about some proteomics analysis
instead of being conducted in a loud of
the tumor microenvironment and with
particular focus to the role of human
primary fabulous directaccess ohms in
oral cancer progression this work is
currently ongoing at Princess Margaret
Cancer Centre here University of Toronto
and this
is my postdoctoral fellow project under
the supervision of dr. Thomas Kissinger
so just to give you a little bit of
background on head and neck Helena
cancers are he's a group very
heterogeneous group of cancers that
includes different tumors the races
above the collarbone and the three major
subdivisions are or cavity bearings and
bearings within the royal cabinet being
the most prevalent as you can see here
from the list each one of these subsides
also had different multiple subside so
in this case particularly for this talk
of before casino and overall Tom which
is the source of my samples the major
risk factors for head and neck are
alcohol and tobacco consumption and
together account for seventy
seventy-five percent of cases despite
few progresses in a surgery and chemo
read his era p over the last ten years i
would say fill the five-year survival
this patient to have it hasn't really
improved so this actually suggests that
there is a strong need to better define
the molecular basics of this cancer and
also the incidence rate are hiring men
as in women from a theological point of
view most of this cancer ninety to
ninety-five percent of them are a
squamous cell carcinomas also called
accs and the remaining five percent is
that accounts for less common
astrologists of their usual variants of
sec s so we can classify all the tumors
based on the percentage of
characterization of the tissue and we
can see are an example of normal
epithelium as well as the well
differentiated modernly or poorly
differentiated tumors that's the latest
stage for Helena cancer or tumor
development from an ecological point of
view we can see how the normal appearing
turns into an eye / plastic and then
evolves to a mild dysplasia and then
turns into severe dysplasia also called
carcinoma in situ and in the latest page
of this cancer is invasive carcinoma
that's a cold invasive because it
becomes usual in that metastatic also in
parallel the molecular level what
happened in the condition of normal
epithelium you can see that the
epithelial cells are very well separated
from the surrounding stroma but by an
interactive basement membrane so the
underneath the stroma contains different
cell types a cellular and non cellular
components and Monticello are confident
there are different components of
extrasolar matrix as indicated here by
the college and bundles for example and
among the set of the cell types are most
common in the tumor stroma we have well
immune cells lymphocytes and as well as
endothelial cells and fibroblasts so
focus my attention on fibroblast today
because what happened when the normal
epithelium sir are becoming turning into
a condition of mile dysplasia you can
see how the fibroblast initially are
cushioned in the stroma start becoming
activated and this activation change and
modifies their phenotype so still you
can see that at the material cells here
indicated in blue are proliferating
that's why the condition is called
dysplasia but they're still very well
separated from the stroma by and intact
basement membrane so what happened next
when the tumor are opposed to invasive
carcinoma is that the activated cell
types such as the fibroblast in this
case of the tumor stroma turns into my
father was phenotype and start secreting
a numerous amount of molecules and
extras our matrix company to contribute
to the stiffness of the tumor as well as
enzyme the degrade there are debate
mmmm brain and they lead to a condition
of mixed cell tied together so this is
the condition of stromal activation
where we have as I mentioned the
tradition of accelerometers component
infiltrate our immune cells as well and
the differentiation of fiber bus into
calves calves stands for cancer
associated fibroblast so the origin of
the cells is still controversial one of
the most popular offices is that as I
just mentioned they are generating by
peregrine activity of cancer cells so
epithelial cancer cells the for example
secret agent data or other interleukins
that actually act as a paracrine
signaling on the subscriber bus and
activate them or other hypotheses are
also support a transition from totally
different cell type as for example
epithelial cells the undergo EMT or
parasite or endothelial cells or other
so type more and then they are also
probably driving from mesenchymal stem
cells so felter come from the
circulation that in this case we have
entered a tumor site as tumor site due
to the leading vessels of the late stage
of the carcinoma and from a fan o
typical point of view are to be
differentiated normal parables form
activated fibroblast so the cafe no type
is mainly characterized by expression of
smooth muscle acting actually different
isoforms but the boats on the marker is
the office ma and this is actually
contributes to the contract contractile
phenotype of the cells that don't look a
fusillade anymore but they look more
spread and they also have a greater rate
of ECM synthesis and secretion and a
resistant to apoptosis
so numerous studies reason we have taken
into account the importance of the tumor
microenvironment in tumor development
because the stroma actively modulates
the biology of the tumor by acting on
the cancer cells the interaction and the
private signal signals between stromal
cells and cancer cells are
bi-directional and extremely dynamic and
calves are a key component in regulating
carcinogenesis so starting from the
hypothesis that the stroma can promote
tumor growth my main project has been to
isolate has been focusing on isolating
kaif cancer-associated fibroblast as
well as adjacent fibroblast that from
now on a local AF from your sector to
merced drive from chong and here you can
see those are 0 SES that stands for oral
squamous cell carcinomas so after
isolating themselves I I have done it in
death proteomics analysis of two
different pathways canonical and
non-canonical secretion of proteins so
I've looked at soluble proteins they are
secreted by the fibroblast and released
in the media as well as I've looked a
non-canonical secretion of exosomes what
are exosomes and just briefly what's the
role in cancer exosomes are not on my
nano nano meter size and solar base
vesicles they range from 40 to 100
nanometer usually and their origin comes
from a multi-vehicle or body formation
this is where their biogenesis come from
we can see the where a stimulus act on
the cells there is the formation of
intraluminal vesicle so then I turn into
early endosome the early endosomes much
for into late endosomes also called mbbs
this stands for a multi distal
bodies because it's big and vesicles
that to have content to contain a
smaller nano vesicle inside and then the
mmm BBS can undergo lysosomal
degradation or confuse with a plasma
membrane and release their content in
the extracellular space so in this case
the content released will be to exosomes
and so the exosomes are released from
different cell type and thus they can be
found in my fluids that also be used as
biomarkers and they're involved in the
intercellular communication among
different cell type what's inside the
exosomes so are they contain a variety
of different molecules ranging from our
protein company lipids and also nucleic
acids exosomes has been quite well
characterized lately and they also have
member markers such as tetris painting
and CD molecules they are used as common
markers to define different vesicle
populations and sony leader have been
described in numerous amount of papers
exosomes role in cancer has been shown
to have effect on fifa tumor
heterogeneity for example on immune
system escape and inhibition and also
having effect on angiogenesis and
metastasis as well as in the
transformation of the fibroblast into
cancer associate fabulous Jim um
regarding mr. DX is from there secreted
from the fibroblast and acts on the
tumor cells so the opposite finnaly
that's object on my study I there's two
papers to my papers they recently came
out and they're worth a mention in this
buildin Davina also co-author of the
nature cell biology one basically both
paper shows in different system how cap
secret exosomes has an effect on have an
effect on cancer cells and different
type of cancer for the South papers
breast cancer system for example and
this activates signal
signal with signals that induce cancer
migration and also angiogenesis so
particularly for this talk the main aim
has been to uncover fabulous bracketing
regulators of tumor progression and I've
shown you that has this been done by
look at soluble proteins as well as XO
soma proteins so on this main aim has
been done through the four main
different steps so the purse aim was to
isolate and characterized primary calf
and AF that has been isolated from
resected Tom cancers the second aim has
been to conduct in-depth proteomics
analysis of calf and AF secret own and
exosomes then evaluated the effects of
everyone's ribosomes on champions
ourselves and laughs we have also been
generating a single map of I was the
cancer cells league of receptor
interaction in order to complete the
picture and sort of close the look of
disparate and signalling so going
through hang one the isolation of human
primary calf and I have and has been
done from resected tumors that come from
the Tong so primary patients those would
be associated into single cells by using
a mixture of two different enzymes
collagen ease and hyaluronidase then
this cell suspension as being further
resuspended in a red blood cells lysis
buffer and the cells have been seated
down on plate so for fried we'll go
specifically the only cells that are
going to adhere to the plate in this
case it's the plastic to do supply
signature dish are the fiber bus and
then the other salt that gets washed off
and of course on the cells then to get
evaluated for positivity positivity to
fibroblast markers and uh negativity to
for example cd31 and affiliates of
marker or the pavillion marker etc so
what happened in parallel to
as light of the two morgan also
undergoes is to pathological evaluation
and so in the end i get also some
clinical info on each patient and have a
final table that gives me also
information about the site
differentiations day is n tumor stage so
the first aim after having isolate the
primary human fibroblast from the tumors
have been to characterized and make sure
the initial system that I'm looking at
recapitulates actually will happen in
vivo and I started by validating this
for the gold standard marker which is
half SMA as indicated here in the West
blood panel that a boat panel show this
version of office ma which is higher
income versus the adjacent fibroblasts
across nine pairs that have been able to
isolate from tone two more and here in
the second panel we're looking at an
immunofluorescence still form of SMA and
we can see how the morphology of the
Caliph's it's a um absolutely different
from the evasion adjacent I robust and
how the office it may actually defines
this contractile fibers there within the
cells so the first four pairs to have
been repaired that i will call from now
on discovery court because those are the
samples that are being further volley
data and then used for the proteomics
analysis and you can see here how I also
looked at their mythology and the
mythology looks different AFR more
alligator where's the cap or more spread
when especially this can be appreciated
when they're serious old and low density
and also I've been conducting a
functional assay which is a collagen one
gel contraction on say we're basically
the cells the federalists are embedded
in a semi solid matrix of collagen one
and then I measure over time the
activity and the capacity of the calf to
the grade and shrank the the semi solid
matrix of collagen so here in the graph
you can see how a six hours basically
the collagen area it's reduced for the
cat marked in red versus digits in five
of us which is the blue dogs and then
the second cohort of patients the
remaining five have been used for as a
validation cohort for more of a
functional assay and validating the
biology after the proteomics funding
suppose specifically going into a number
to the shotgun proteomics workflow which
is the strategy that we applied here in
the lab and there I've been optimizing
for this cell type consists of on
protein extraction from calf and is and
for this we use TFE which is an organic
solvent actually extracts the really
well membrane proteins then proteins are
adjusted into that tight by using
trypsin peptides are separated by
culture high pressure liquid
chromatography and then you're analyzed
into a mass spectrometer and here in the
lab would be missing a QE so the final
data has are analyzed by used to be by
using a maximum platform and searched by
Andromeda algorithm so and this will
allow us to have a semi-quantitative
idea of the proteins now list by using a
pic integration integration method are
connected to the software so after that
of course more bioinformatic filters and
more data mining is being applied to the
final list of proteins in order to deal
with more manageable Lisa proteins also
to find some image protein signatures
that were interested in looking at so a
little bit more in legal team to the
prodigal that has been used for
economics I mean seeding uh I've been
working on or a different pairs of cap
and is so for a total of eight cell
lines from each of them happy
extracting I'm analyzing of three
different fraction the hotel I stayed
the conditioned media and the exosome
attraction the hotel isida is being
processed as I just mentioned by TFE
extraction whereas the media has been
further concentrated and the exosome
have been isolated by a standard
differential ultracentrifugation
protocol by using a back man sought
refuge and then all those three fraction
so that's a total 24 different fraction
has been run in triplicate allies but by
lc-ms and for total 72 runs that gave me
a final list of proteins identified and
quantified of 4247 so this is my final
final data set and to just start a
little bit more of data mining with this
proteins I've been looking at soluble
molecules released in the media there
are known to be enriched in the cap
versus the adjacent I robust and as we
can see here in this box plot different
kinds of collagen one are hired a highly
secretive Ana Calif versus their Jason
fiberglass is significantly enriched in
the medial to salt as well as the
secretion of extracellular matrix
component and here i'm reporting Ellis
Tina for directing type 3 and spark and
also I've looked at the exosome fraction
to validate it further and here you can
see in the first image representatives
are pictures all on electron microscopy
analysis after our isolation protocol
and in the bar chart is that at the
bottom we can see how when we look at
protein intensity of excess or most
specific markers here are shown in bread
those are enriched where is a
cytoplasmic marker that are belonging to
different compartment Williams cells are
depleted India to someone for action as
we expect
so moving forward to more in-depth into
the data after having this just hit map
shows summarizes all the final data and
this is based on a hunter provides two
hierarchical clustering so the way to
Rita is the highest is the darkest the
color that a most abundant is the
protein what we learn from this heat map
is that the three fraction that have
been analyzing have split nicely between
each other and you can see also that
there are different clusters to show up
for example the light blue at the bottom
it's more of a background cluster that
contains high intensity proteins their
present in every fraction but they're
also we can get also nice information if
we want to look at a single fraction and
this is the case of the light green
blaster and more at the top instead that
we can say it's more enriched for
proteins that are present in the
utilizing but not present in the
conditioned media or enjoy exosomes and
then after this I would just focusing
mainly my attention on the secret term
and looking at the conditioned media and
exosome attraction and while using the
whole delighted as a background all the
time so the first finding that that I
I've noticed by looking at this data is
that exosomes are actually enriched in
proteins they're involved in a
regulation of cancer cell migration and
in fact if we could look at this in map
that represent a shorter list of
proteins that are actually contained in
the gene ontology analysis under the
regulation of salt again sir cell
migration term we can see how a seventy
percent of proteins are enriched in the
X Osama fraction versus the conditioned
media and the way to look at this is my
base exactly at the previous one the
darker color means the protein is more
abundant
and if we assume a little bit more into
this proteins they're almost barely a
present into conditioned media that
comes up to be a list of under 51 are
proteins and this list a reporter here
and this view more of a zoomed-in view
and this list is actually contains lots
of uncle genes and proteins are known to
be involved in cancer cell proliferation
and progression such as a trois egfr or
vcr for example and then the last thing
i wanna point out about this image is
that visually for looking truly the
distinction between cap and i add as
indicated at the top of the map we don't
see visually a great difference in a
protein expression but i was able to go
mine will be for the list and select if
you can do that are actually a couple
candidate in this case endoglin and
icam-1 there are their enriched in the
caf exosome versus their Jason follow us
and invalidating this in a different
cohort of patients in the X Osama
fraction as you can see here in the West
bought images hmm so this first analysis
suggested me that from above exosome
might contain key signaling proteins
they're related to cancer progression
and specifically cancer cell migration
so to test this I first wanted to
validate that the signaling of the the
paracrine signaling and I've been
treating the SE since 25 which is the
oral cancer actually Tom cancer
commercially available cell lines that's
immortalized and stable I've been
treating the CC 25 with exosomes and
being just evaluating the uptake by
marking dick system with a lipophilic
for us and died and we can see six hours
we can already see a green signal that
taken and just get strong at 24 hours so
after having verified this I
wanted to mainly evaluate the effect of
exosomes on cancer cell migration and so
for this I used pretty much the same
setup I've been treating sec 25 with the
exosome mole fraction as well as with
the EFM that we can see here as
indicated in red the FM stands for the
exosome three media which is basically
the supernatant to come from the after
having spent down the exosome outlet so
it doesn't contain vesicles and here you
can see this a panel of blood for
fulfilling one which is an excellent
marker and that's just to check the
purity of the two fraction so flotillin
only shows in the exosome attraction
across two different patients analyzed
and reported here and then what happen
when we treat a cc is 25 with exosomes
we can see here represents the image of
seven different patient that are being
analyzing so far where the excellent
treatment enhances all cancer cell
migration will respect to the control
and also with respect to the EFM so the
same thing was shown here in the cart
and this is a representative experiment
from one patient and this box blood
instead shows how the trend is always
this the same and the numbers are so
significant when we look at seven
different patients so furthermore I
decided to test my since my hypothesis
is based on in fact on a protein content
within the exosomes and I've added a
further negative control and up it's
shown here in this curve as in dark the
dark blue line and 45 being boiling the
exosomes in order to the nature of the
protein and I've been tweeting that
CeCe's 25 as well as with a coil to
access on toilet at the same
concentration and we see the
there is no effect the curb actually
overlaps with the control so this
validates my hypothesis that's based
upon some proteomics funding that some
proteomic company with envy exosomes is
actually are financing the cancer cell
migration in this case and in this box
boy I show the same experiment by animal
so at the AF exosomes njf and irfan
counterpart and so we can see how the
treatment with adjacent I robust
exosomes by showing here in orange it's
still significant versus to control and
there is no significant difference
between a FX with some and cat excellent
treatment all there is always a trend
that I'd be observing across the my
experiment and here this is the lexus
pair might have been conducting or by
also adding and treatment with
counteract microvesicles which are the a
bigger bicycle fraction that's usually
range from 1 micro micron and we can see
how there's no significant effect versus
a control and this is fadi suspect is
comparable to the one that's given by
the EFM treatment so moving forward on
this this adenine dominating also the
affected kappa suit exosomes on a cancer
cell growth and similar results has been
shown here the exosomes are enhancing
sec is 25 growth stimulator operation
and this is a significant versus the
control and also significant versus the
EFM EFM still has the treatment with a
justin.tv still has an exact vs. to
control but its way minor than the
exosome 01 and I've also been observing
that what I cc's are treated me like so
so much Aled there is an activation of
the map kinase pathway which can explain
also a day fat
we have been surveying here on some
roads and cell migration we're going a
little bit deeper into the caf exosomes
and going back to the proteomics
signature I wanted to find excess formal
and rich proteins only contained in the
end cap so for doing this I started out
buying some filtering criteria to the
full data set in order to select for
those proteins are enriched in the cast
specifically so i took the list of
exosomes and i am rich for CAF proteins
there are exactly higher in the CAF
versus the Jason fiberglass by giving a
p-value point zero five then a full
change or 1.5 and then also the protein
had to be higher in the cap in at least
three out of the four pairs that are
being analyzing in the screening in the
proteomics screening so I need lead me
to a final list of under 80 proteins and
we can see this protein here visualized
in a kumquat we're in the x-axis it's a
ratio between cap and AF and whereas in
the y-axis is the p value and the dark
color in here represents the protein has
a reach to eat in three out of four
pairs patients so that culminated
proteins that I'm talking about are
localized in the area within the red
lines and wit by the dark color so then
I applied the same filtering criteria
also to the cell media as well as to the
cell lysate fraction and I came up with
this pretty small based proteins that
here we can see in the Venn diagram of
the overlap within each other and also
there is five proteins that are commonly
found and reached in the car versus day
Jason Farnham lost across all this
refraction that have been analyzing my
quarry onyx and just as consistent and
we can see where those five proteins map
here in the gamma plot this work is
still ongoing and where
validating one of these proteins so I
won't show those proteins will stay
anonymous for today I just want to show
that I've done some for the validation
in the politician for doctors for
patients in on in life States and in a
pool of exosomes for one of them and
we're actually validating despite
immunochemistry naina impatience so I'm
going back to the cap exosome and rich
protein signature I took the small list
of proteins that are rich in the caf and
here indicated in red and I compare this
to the wonders that are at the bottom of
the list of this comparison so there are
enriched linearly adjacent fibroblastic
when I compare this to smallness for
proteins and ran a gene ontology
analysis this has been done by using the
far each software what it's one of the
striking difference that I notice
immediately is day enrichment ain't a
calf are exosomes for proteins are
involved in a metabolism and energetic
pathways and if i zoom more into this
lisa proteins and those are mainly
enzymes and it's at least so51 proteins
those are involved in different
biological pathway sir metabolismo
nucleotides purane lipoprotein and
brutus degradation as we can see here in
the graph and this doesn't apply to the
same comparison with the same comparison
is not on a hotel ice age so it seems
like there is something that's
specifically enriched in the exosomes
and in the caf exosomes and it's
involved in in metabolic pathways and
this hit map here shows in the in red
the proteins that are perfectly enriched
in the CAF exosomes and we consider
intensity of these proteins he ain jf
fraction is a much lower and the same
condition does not apply for the
silicate as i just mentioned by looking
at
from each analysis so here it comes the
next question it took up exosomes
simulate tumor metabolic activity on sec
selves and our this also experiment are
currently on growing up in analyzing
evaluating our lucas metabolism i might
encounter such tests by using a source
analysis and the theta so preliminary so
i will not discuss it today so i just
summarizing would have shown you so far
maybe we'll be looking at the effects of
x to the party on of the exosomes coming
from fibroblast to more fabulous and
normal fiber bus as well as the effect
of exorcism on oral cancer cells but
then to complete intersect the signaling
more index i've also have completed
analysis of the solver proteins dar
least by the 50 West and here if we zoom
Aldous a fraction we can see in this 3d
plot how marketing read a smaller listo
422 media enriched proteins and those
are the protein there which in the media
versus their exosomes and cell lysate
and here is the gene ontology analysis
shows the quality of this protein and
those are mainly extra sour protein
secreted etc and so to complete this
network we also looked at our receptors
and plasma membrane protein on the
recipient salts so in this case on the
world cancer cells and this has been
done are still by applying mass spec
based proteomics on two different cell
lines FCC 25 and SEC 20 msec for and
they're both are derived from Tom cancer
the saline has been grown till monolayer
and then the monolayer has encoded with
a colloidal solution of silica needs so
those beads are out
urgent they electrostatically interacted
with a surface molecules percent on
cells and then the membrane fraction can
be cooled down by pulling down the bids
and by purifying the fraction in by
doing ultracentrifugation on inoculants
grading actually so in the end what we
get is a pellet of plasma membrane which
is enriched proteins which surface
molecules as well as we also process by
lc-ms the homogeny fraction again to
have it as a background more like a
control to look at our enrichment so
this lid need to identify 5757 proteins
and this was the blood here is just a
pan of the validate how member proteins
such as egfr or CDA one are only present
and reach that actually fairly clean in
the plasma mmmm fraction versus the
membrane between a diffraction whereas
internal intra solar protein are only a
present in the MV fraction and not into
plasma membrane and if we do a gene
ontology analysis of this proteins again
we can see how there are plasma membrane
protein arm of sec cells in this case is
enriched for a for cellular component in
plasma membrane proteins for Biological
project process of course this like
Richmond teen saal addition to Simon
transport and when we look at molecular
function we see how we have a
transporter activity signal receptor
protein kinase etc so and this is
precisely what one look at and we're
interested in looking at so the
proteomic analysis of plasma protein
lead us to a smaller list of 1500 plasma
membrane and rich proteins and this list
of the plasma membrane protein will be
in that heat greater which is
written that comes from the fabulous
just remind us at least of 422 mini rich
proteins and so this will be done and is
currently actually going on going by
aligning those are rich list to database
that's how we decide to proceed old
legal receptor-mediated muscle signal
singular signaling in human that has
been recently published on initial
communication and so this is because one
finally have a whole picture of the
parabola signals of the tumor
microenvironment and to address i'm for
i want to build a more comprehensive
model that's based on a map of ligand
receptor interaction of the tumor
microenvironment in henan cancers so
just to conclude for today i've shown
you how I successfully isolate and
characterize kappa Nia from Tom tumors
and been conducting in-depth proteomics
analysis on three different fraction of
the spells the media to see ad exosome
fraction and the hopeful I state I was
able to highlight a captioning twerking
signature in exosomes and also to
validate one of the markers that can be
in the future also utilized as a calf
specific marker of the cob activating
stroma which at the moment we're
currently lacking and also how to cap
secure exosomes can stimulate sec is 25
motility and proliferation and this is
also process that probably due to the
activation of my kind of signaling
pathways in the same cells as you sure
gold I I am analyzing and investigating
us investigating the facts of
California's exosomes on a cici's
metabolic functions and also i'm
building a mess based ligand-receptor
repertoire of the tumor microenvironment
in order to better
detective signaling can have a more
insight into this tumors so I'm with
this is all for today and I would like
to acknowledge my mentor dr. Thomas
Kissinger as well as the members of my
lab to have been contributing directly
and indirectly to this project and our
collaborators dr. Laurie else and people
in our lab Acura Angelina and injured
John for having realizing one of the
occurred to me to some of the nice pep
tunes to be showing to you today as well
as my fondants and of course special
thanks to Beckman culture and lab roads
for giving me the opportunity today to
present this webinar and thanks to all
of you for your attention I'll be glad
to see any question great thank you for
that terrific presentation simona before
we get started on the question and
answer session i would like to remind
our audience that you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window several good questions have
already came in today our first question
is which markers are used to
characterize the AF and CAF's okay so
that
very interesting question are we
measuring something Jeremy talk the main
markers are used to characterize the cat
phenotype so that calf activated
fibroblasts activated phenotype are a
smooth muscle acting protein the FSMA
and the gamma and also as well as some
secret proteins such as increase in
collagen one production by capsules and
also this pin is known the Cassie create
our proteinases such as I'm in peace and
a p1 and p2 timp-1 and protest are
involved in debating the excess or
matrix and in creating the degradation
of the basement membrane as i showed
before so those are the main markers
known so far but much to do much more
hiss it needs to be done on the
pressurization of the salt great thank
you for that answer our next question
that comes in is did you do any
proteomics on the resected tumors to sa
the exosomes oh yes and wide any depth
of proteomic analysis have been done on
all the exosomes oh but not other
content on the tumor counterpart well
the tumor has been analyzed as well
because the hotel I say today we're
looking at emporia mix analysis actually
comes from South de have been isolated
so I'm perfected primary tumors so yes
the proteomic analysis is very broad and
opposing thats and contained all the
possible fraction including hosel isaac
exosomes and secret time
great thank you for that along the same
lines a question was has lipidomics been
used to characterize the phospholipid or
lipid composition of these exosomes oh
that's a very interesting question oh
yes lipidomics has a heavy news to go
after I exosomes not particularly for
this kind of tumors but there is some
lipidomics announced they still must
like based on for example prostate
cancer cells pc3 and a few other cell
cancer cell type of course the lipid
ohmic field is a not as advanced as the
proteomics but yes there are studies
that actually had to find develop atomic
salt and optic axis ohms terrific I
think we have time for one more question
is there any influence of immune
associated molecules like chemokines on
the team on the tumor milieu on the
exosomes of CAS oh another very
interesting question and so the reefs
the chemokines and turn accounts have
absolutely a key role in the development
of this cancer as well as in the private
activity that goes from the cancer cells
to the fibroblast and this versa and yes
there is a repertory motives are known
to be secreted from the cancer cell such
as for example tgf-beta or interleukin-6
they are not activate the fibroblast in
the tumor stroma as well as there are
chemicals and intervenes they're also
secreted from the fibroblast and goes
the other way to the two more
thank you again unfortunately we are out
of time today I want to thank the
audience for their interesting questions
and participation in today's event I
would also like to thank our sponsor
beckman coulter and of course dr. Simona
principe for making today's educational
webcast possible which will also be
available for on-demand viewing through
beckman coulter calm and Laberge calm
thanks again goodbye